but right now what we've got is
certainty
at least for the raider fans that we're
going to have full capacity without
masks in that stadium
and
for for that that certainty i'm just
very thankful to the governor for coming
up with something that will work for us
well i just support the decisions that
are being made every state every team is
probably going to have a different view
on this i support
the decision that was made i'll be
anxious to see as many raiders fans as
possible with no mask
that's what i'm excited about they can
make more noise that way but
i know it's a touchy subject for a lot
of people but i do support
the direction we're heading and i
encourage everybody to that i know to
get the vaccine and come and join us
um we know it's the right thing to do
we know it's the right way to keep
this stadium full all season long
and to create the game day experience
that our fans love and miss and remember
where they can cheer for their team
without mass gather with their friends
and family
and have the good time that they all
remember having
governor sislek was dealt a pretty bad
hand
things are going pretty good here in las
vegas when the pandemic hit
and uh he's had to scramble every which
way but loose
and there's been no certainty and there
still is no certainty i think people
forget that we're still in the middle of
a pandemic
it's not over yet
and so
we've listened to governor sislek we've
spoken with him on number of things and
i think what he came up with here was uh
two two options that we could have
followed and health and safety is always
number one in everything that we do
and we just feel that this part of the
process
the way that he came up with it is uh
the one that we're going to follow
um
our focus here community ambulances to
help support the initiative that the
raiders are put have put forth uh we'll
be providing vaccinations on site for
those that have not received their
vaccination um we'll be able to process
that here on site they'll receive their
vaccine card at that point and they'll
then be able to follow the protocol to
then get it uploaded to clear so
we're happy to to support this community
like like many we're a part of this
community we want to get this community
open to 100 percent we want to we want
to do it safely we want to do it
effectively and and we're here to
support those efforts
but we're really excited about the
opportunity to have consistency this
season
and uh
i would say that
if people are concerned about taking the
uh the shot or whatever that we will
refund their money for the season for
the nine games
we'll give them a full refund
or they can roll their uh
ticket money over till next season if in
fact they roll it over till next season
they'll get the
full 10 game season for the nine games
that they're returning
um if in fact they get a refund
they will then just pay next year the
full price for their season tickets
which will be the same price as this
year's